mais d'abord une hypothèse marine le pen
l'emportent le 24 avril qui pour formé
son premier gouvernement la candidate
d'extrême droite et discrète sur ce
point norbert évangéliste à ses
détracteurs qui doutent de sa capacité à
former un gouvernement la candidate du
rassemblement national ironise j'ai
toutes les équipes qu'il me faut je
pourrais même en constituer quatre ou
cinq bons et si marine le pen prétend
déjà connaître sans le dévoiler le nom
de son premier ministre seuls deux noms
circulent dont sont pressentis les
affectations au premier rang desquels
jean paul garraud l'ancien républicain
ancien magistrat hériterait
naturellement de la justice
erbi juvin conseiller régional des pays
de loire farouche défenseur du nucléaire
récolterez lui le ministère de
l'écologie le nom de franck allisio est
également citée sans savoir quelle place
occupera le vice-président du parti dans
l'éventuelle gouvernement d'extrême
droite on ne sait pas non plus quel
serait son rôle mais fidèle parmi les
fidèles jordan bardella aura sa place
garantie au sein de l'exécutif le pen
mais qui pour prendre les autres
marocains la candidate d'extrême droite
là sur quinze ministres seront nommés et
que ses équipes travaillent activement à
dresser la liste des noms manquants des
gens que vous ne connaissez pas sur la
candidate aux fonctionnaires chefs
d'entreprise ou issus de la société
civile marine le pen ne ferme pas non
plus la porte à des personnalités
d'autres partis partageant des points de
convergence mais exclut paradoxalement
d'accueillir le chef du parti reconquête
non ça n'est pas une possibilité il n'en
a pas le souhait je n'en n'ai pas le
choix non plus j'ai exprimé tout au long
de la campagne du premier tour les
divergences que je pouvais avoir avec
eric zemmour mais j'ai lu et toujours g
comment dire concéder sans aucune
difficulté d'ailleurs qu'il faisait
partie du camp de ceux qui croient en la
france enfin parce qu'elle avait trahi
le clan ont choisi sans de rejoindre les
rangs de l'ancien chroniqueur non je ne
prendrai pas marion maréchal dans mon
gouvernement demant
sa propre nièce n'aurait rien à attendre
si marine le pen gagner l'élection
présidentielle
notre premier débat dans ce sens public
je vous présente mes invités claire
chartier bonsoir vous êtes journaliste
et essayiste bienvenue gilles
finchelstein bonsoir vous êtes le
directeur général de la fondation jean
jaurès bienvenue à vous je rappelle que
vous avez pour me donnait déjà parlé
dans cette émission la fondation qui a
publié à 10 jours ce dossier le pen
idéologie images électorale stewart
chaumont soir si voir bienvenue
responsable des études politiques et
sociétales à l'institut de sondages
viavoice
hauteur de l'opinion des émotions c'est
aux éditions de lomé j'accueille
également mathieu croissandeau
éditorialiste politique bonsoir
malicieuse ou alors on va parler
longuement dans cette émission du
contenu de la conférence de presse de
marine le pen sur les questions
internationales ce sera même le thème de
notre second débat autour de l'europe et
de l'otan donc il y aura ne vous
inquiétez pas beaucoup de questions sur
le fond mais on va commencer sur la
forme et sur cet incident lors de la
conférence ea je propose à quand un
calme est de nous rejoindre quand un bon
soir vous étiez
sur place tout conférence je le disais
en titre perturbé perturbé par quatre
militants qui ont été exfiltrés
rapidement de la salle exactement la
conférence avait commencé depuis à peu
près une heure et un des militants
effectivement un des quatre militants
placés dans la salle parmi les juristes
a réussi à obtenir le micro pour poser
une question
il s'est fait passer pour un juriste de
russia today a expliqué que vladimir
poutine s'inquiétait de ne plus avoir
des nouvelles de marine le pen au même
moment dans la salle vous allez le voir
une autre militante a levé une pancarte
avec au milieu d'un coeur la photo de
marine le pen et de vladimir poutine qui
avait été découpé une vraie photo 1 qui
date de leur rencontre à empruntant au
printemps 2010 est alors très rapidement
vous le voyez le service d'ordre a sorti
la militante de la salle toute une
partie des journalistes a décroché la
conférence pour comprendre ce qui se
passait la militante qui tenait une
photo a été exfiltré al étage du lieu
qui accueillait à la conférence de
presse alors d'abord tenu à l'écart la
presse a ensuite pu se rapprocher de ce
qui se passait dans le couloir ou trois
autres militants répondaient aux
questions des journalistes écouter l'un
d'eux à notre micro aujourd'hui on dit
non c'est la maison de marie noëlle au
mali
la complaisance de l'extrême droite en
général et donc moment là vous une
question au nom de richesse
c'est notre cas types de jouets l'humour
perdu 7,1 et cher et l'amitié et qui a
disparu du jour au lendemain une
élection plus
ces militants thomas sont membres du
collectif ibisa il s'était fait
connaître cet hiver avec le sosie de
jean michel blanquer au moment de la
mobilisation des enseignantes et non
plus tard dans l'après midi ils ont
posté des photos indiquant que la
militante celle qu'on se voit être
traînés au sol elle n'était pas blessée
qu'elle avait pu repartir sans
difficulté du lieu alors juste une
dernière petite question que vous vous
posez peut-être comment des militants
ont-ils pu réussir à s'infiltrer parmi
des journalistes et bien en fait on a
insisté nous à l'événement cet après
midi c'est vrai que les services d'ordre
sont arrivés après les premiers
journalistes à cette conférence de
presse il était donc peut-être déjà
installé lorsqu'on a commencé la
conférence de presse merci quentin pour
ce témoignage clair chartier ça fait un
peu désordre quand même est-ce qu'on
peut dire ça ou est ce qu'il faut c'est
dur c'est un incident de campagne comme
il y en a chaque à chaque présidentielle
et ne lui donnant pas plus d'importance
enfin pas non plus car tu es quand même
l'idée que les militants se sont aussi
un petit peu un petit peu fait monter la
sauce précisément pour que j'y cherche
qui est en train de
culture rassemblement national où c'est
l'ordre qui prévaut est précisément
c'est cette symbolique il faut mettre en
avant et puis de l'autre côté une
agit-prop un peu années soixante dix on
y va avec l'humour et on essaie de faire
passer le message avec l'humour donc là
ce qui est assez voilà ce qui est assez
marquant c'est ce contraste ce contraste
là qui est pas si étonnant donc quelque
part gilles finchelstein imaginons
l'inversé il ya une scène comme celle là
à une conférence de presse des modèles
macron
ou lors d'un déplacement à lorient il ya
beaucoup d'opposants quand emmanuel
macron se déplace il est chahuté il se
fait traiter nul
je crois que c'était ce matin oui hier
pardon hier il a pris du temps pour
répondre est-ce que voilà et ça aurait
été un scandale si ça s'était passé lors
d'un meeting ou d'un déplacement des
mains est évidemment était un scandale
et je pense que cet incident malgré tout
est révélateur de quelque chose vous
disiez la forme en fait dès souvent la
forme c'est le fond qui remonte à la
surface et c'est intéressant par rapport
à tout ce qui a été la stratégie de
marine le pen dans cette campagne qui
était de neutraliser toutes les arêtes
de son programme de donner un sentiment
de pacification c'est ce qu'on montre
dans le dossier que vous avez évoquées
et dans le même temps de travailler
simplement sur son image personnelle est
ce que ce cet incident montre il fait
suite déjà à ce qui s'est passé hier
avec quotidien c'est tout ça alors il
faut rappeler ce qui s'est passé c'est
lequel elle a refusé que un journaliste
au quotidien puisse participer à sa
conférence de presse ont considéré qu'il
n'était pas journaliste coincé c'est
grosso modo en disant je décide de qui
participent âme et conscience tout cela
vient craquelé l'image et c'est sur quoi
c'est intéressant et puis ce qui est
intéressant aussi c'est sur quoi sa
porte ce week-end deux mesures m eacute
in c'est-à-dire un point sur lequel de
manière manifeste de manière réitérée de
manière constante marine le pen a été
pendant des années
dans l'erreur et elle a eu l'habileté à
la dickens d'eric zemmour de changer de
position rapidement et radicalement mais
c'est se rappelle là aussi lit sans
doute lui était insupportable d'ailleurs
ce thème stewart on avait le sentiment
que ça ne prenait pas avant le premier
tour sur l'électorat de marine le pen
est ce qu'on peut
on peut se projeter sur ce qui peut
apparaître comme un boulet dans sa
campagne d'ailleurs la stratégie de
marine le pen je pense de placer cette
conférence de presse sur l'international
en début de semaine second tour c'était
peut-être pour évacuer les questions
autour de son admiration on va dire pour
le président russe est ce que ça peut
quand même resté un boulet pour aller
c'est vrai que ce qui est intéressant
pour rebondir sur ce que disait gilles
très justement ces cas là quand même
gérer elle s'est sortie de cette
séquence secren plutôt bien avec une
sociologie d'un électorat qui était
peut-être moins sensibles à la question
à comparaison avec eric zemmour qui a
dégringolé à partir du moment où il
s'est aussi prononcé manière un peu
douteuse sur c'est sur ces questions là
avec des connivences que l'on que l'on
connaît pour le deuxième temps de la
campagne c'est difficile à dire non à
ping quand on a réalisé ce sondage jour
du vote auprès des électeurs de marine
le pen il semblerait qu'effectivement la
crise en ukraine et pas forcément
impacter le vote marine le pen est ce
que ça le sera sur cette seconde partie
de la campagne on ignore encore ce qui
est quand même intéressant et vous lui
disiez c'est que lé vaincu très très
vite les traits d'image auquel elle sait
être en mauvaise posture par rapport à
emmanuel macron c'est à dire la
crédibilité sur la scène internationale
les questions de relations
internationales les questions aussi de
d'attractivité de la france sur la scène
européenne et mondiale donc on sent bien
qu'il ya une marine le pen qui est assez
attentive finalement à ne pas être
décontenancé finalement par ce fait deux
campagnes passées qui pourrait ressurgir
ici d'ailleurs la capacité qu'a la
aujourd'hui à exclure totalement eric
zemmour de son schéma de gouvernement
éventuel le montre assez bien mais ça
nous ramène sur la question dont on va
parler dans dans une minute avec qui
pourrait-elle gouverner mais tu as un
mot sur c'est sur ces images et concerts
fête au vieux meeting du front national
c'était des images qu'on voyait des
altercations des prises à partie entre
le service d'ordre et des journalistes
le physique ça m'a fait plutôt penser au
front national jean marie le pen
quelques hommes gilles vient de le
rappeler qu'elle tente à tout prix
d'enterrer enfin c'est que c'est
l'inconscient qui frappent à la porte
d'une certaine façon est sûre poutine
aux fourneaux part à travers mais elle a
bénéficié qu'un mini bleus mansuétude
incroyable de la part de tout le monde
parce que qu'est ce qu'elle dit elle dit
oui je suis allé voir vladimir poutine
en 2017
mais c'était pour lui parler de la lutte
contre le terrorisme parce que la france
venait de vider attentats et et il
fallait que en tant que future
présidente je puisse aborder ce point
avec lui n'importe quoi il n'y a pas du
tout été pour cela il était pour
crédibiliser sa stature internationale
puis elle dit aussi contre lui dit oui
vous avez un tract vous savez une un
tract est qu'à la graine qu'elle n'a
plus qu'il n'a pas distribué comme j'ai
dit oui mais c'était avant avant le
craignent enfin avant l' ukraine
vladimir poutine était vladimir poutine
bien connu pour tous ses méfaits c'est
le crès n'abat pas fondamentalement
changé l'image de vladimir poutine donc
il avait fait la même chose ailleurs en
france cyril graux soutenir le rappeler
dix fois donc aimé je trouve que
personne n'a cherché vraiment là coincée
et ça sera évidemment un des angles
d'attaqué et seo déjà un angle d'attaqué
des modèles mâcon lang a rappelé que lui
n'a pas emprunté l'argent la russie que
nul n'est pas un habitué des comptines
et c'est clair chartier sur sur le fond
même si ça aux gens la forme de cette de
cette conférence de presse il ya il ya
un mot qui est important c'est le mot
crédibilité elle cherche à donner une
image de crédibilité sur ces questions
internationales alors elle a quand même
du travail honnêtement parce que
précisément c'est pas sa force et ses
cartes maîtresses sûr
sur poutine sur la russie et notamment
elle récidive quand même c'est assez
remarquable là en disant qu' après la
guerre il faudra que la france enfin il
faudra qu'on s'en approche de la russie
et le disais avant déjà que la france
gagnerait à être dans leurs beats russe
alors c'est comme si effectivement il
n'y avait pas eu l'ukraine donc là on
est presque on est au delà de l'ordre du
déni c'est presque la faute historique
fallait véritablement le contresens
historique donc elle récidive sur un
plan plus général sur les questions
internationales
elle n'a pas de vision géopolitique du
tout elle n'a pas de conseillers de
poids sur ces questions là elle commet
des erreurs grâce elle a encore dit il
ya quelques jours à la radio que
monsieur bourguiba avait interdit le
voile dans la rue ce qui est
parfaitement inexact donc elle a ét at
elle pensé à l'algérie donc elle a
mélangé effectivement de thé playboy
voilà ce qui est quand même un peu
malheureux pour pour quelqu'un qui se
pique d'être une future présidente de la
république donc sur ces questions là
effectivement elle a beaucoup de chemin
à parcourir est allé assez peu crédible
je suis assez d'accord c'est assez
curieux finalement le peu de alors ça
commence à venir quand même hein parce
qu'il ya des choses précises mais on ne
lui c'est padre du tout on ne lui en
veux absolument pas de 7,2 ce
fourvoiement et mais en plus le plus
vraiment le plus le plus complet de
l'histoire c'est qu'elle continue et
c'est là où on aimerait comprendre un
petit peu là là où elles se situent quel
est l'intérêt en fait quel est l'intérêt
stratégique pourquoi continuer avec une
finalement dessiner un axe alors qu'on
sait qu'ils aient poutine
oui juste un mot quand on déroule le
film de ces derniers mois la singularité
de la situation c'est que c'est pas la
campagne qui a fait l'événement c'est
l'événement qui a fait la campagne et
parmi ces événements il ya eu la crise
sanitaire la cinquième vague en janvier
il ya eu la guerre en ukraine et la
guerre en ukraine a eu pour effet de
rêver lui la hiérarchie des qualités qui
sont les plus importantes pour les
français pour le président de la
république et ça arrive à lui et
notamment qui a le plus la stature d'un
chef d'état qui a le plus sa crédibilité
internationale qui sont deux des
qualités sur lesquelles avantage relatif
des manuels macron par rapport à marine
le pen est la plus forte ça n'appelle
beaucoup d'effet dans un premier tour
parce que c'est un premier tour dans un
second tour où là il s'agit de choisir
le président de la république la
question se pose de savoir si ça n'aura
pas davantage d sauf que la guerre en
ukraine elle a fait remonter mais
façon radicale de la question du pouvoir
d'achat qui est cette question là elle
elle porte marine le pen et malgré les
réponses de du gouvernement nombreuses
en milliards manifestement c'est encore
là dessus qu'on va qu'on va chercher
emmanuel macron tous les jours quand il
est en déplacement vous avez raison
quand on regarde pour le coup sûr un
film encore plus long depuis septembre
l'évolution de la hiérarchie des
préoccupations des français peu à peu
depuis janvier le pouvoir d'achat est
devenu la préoccupation écrasante et la
force de la campagne de marine le pen et
d'avoir en tout cas réussi à faire
croire qu'elle était la campagne la
candidate du pouvoir d'achat est un des
défis des manuels macron et d'aller
aussi de ne pas abandonner ce terrain et
de ne pas se contenter du discours qui a
été trop longtemps tenu qu'ils aient
regardé les statistiques
regardez ce qui s'est passé durant le
dernier quinquennat quand les
statistiques sont à ce point orthogonale
aux perceptions des français c'est qu'il
ya un problème elle va aussi voir ton
termine là dessus elle va quand même moi
j'ai le sentiment plus se jouer sur
cette question du pouvoir d'achat que
sur le la stature internationale de
marine le pen cette élection ce qui est
intéressant c'est que d'un point de vue
de l'opinion on vote pour marine le pen
et pour l manuel macro pour des raisons
complètement différente effectivement au
vote pour hommes emmanuel macron
massivement pour sa stature
présidentielle par sa capacité sa
crédibilité sur ces enjeux là notamment
les enjeux économiques et on vote pour
marine le pen beaucoup plus pour son
projet de rupture et de changement donc
effectivement cette campagne elle se
faire aussi la façon où les candidats
pour la porte et je pense que pour
emmanuel macro et gilles a raison de le
rappeler il a tout intérêt à faire de
cette campagne de second tour une
campagne sur le terrain des idées parce
que sont les terrains de l'incarnation
et de l'empathie il part quand même avec
beaucoup de difficultés notamment parce
qu'on est dans une campagne du pouvoir
d'achat et que marine le pen d'aidé
d'ailleurs bien avoir la séquence
zemmour c'était très très très une
manière avait anticipé très en amont
cette capacité finalement à reprendre
cette thématique et d'ailleurs elle est
jugée plus crédible qu emmanuel macron
en dépit effectivement des bons
résultats donc sa marque aussi un temps
d'avancé de la candidate alors j'en
viens à la question de 2,1 gouvernement
qui pourrait gouverner qui pourrait
entourer marine le pen si elle arrivait
au pouvoir
claire chartier depuis dimanche moi ce
qui me marque quand même c'est que
marine le pen a choisi de donner l'image
d'une femme seule il n'y a pas eu de 2,2
de soutien affiché de deux poids lourds
autour d'elle les conférences de presse
elle est bien toujours en solo ce qui
peut être d'ailleurs assez cohérent avec
le rendez-vous de la vème république
entre le président et le peuple alors il
ya une volonté stratégique forcément
mais est-ce que c'est pas aussi un signe
de faiblesse alors d'abord je pense que
ça a trait à c'est précisément ce qu'on
vient de dire c'est à dire que la grande
question pour marine le pen c'était de
convaincre les français qu'elle était
crédible en tant que présidente c'était
vraiment c'est la question et c'est
quand on arrive avec crédible aux yeux
de l'opinion dans une carrière politique
c'est qu'effectivement on a gagné déjà
on a fait déjà une bonne partie du
chemin donc c'était sa grande question
la bataille de l'image elle l'a gagné
souvenez-vous il ya quelques mois on
disait que cette campagne cette élection
allait finalement opposé deux
détestation ceux qui détestent macron
ceux qui détestent marine le pen et
nous allions voir quels détestation
l'emportait bon visiblement ce qui se
passe c'est que on déteste beaucoup
moins marine le pen et on déteste
toujours autant emmanuel macron donc
elle a gagné la bataille de l'image et
les miens un soin très particulier
regardez ce qu'est le soin qu'elle prête
à juste en assises à la couleur de sa
garde-robe nous avions le blanc de
l'immaculée candidate maintenant on a le
sombre du tailleur la présidentiable
responsable qui prend lé dossier à bras
le corps il apparaît notamment sur sa
dernière affiche à tout seul une rando
campagne ça paraît un détail mais dans
la civilisation de l'image dans laquelle
nous sommes ça n'est pas du tout un
détail donc je pense que ça a trait à ça
c'est à dire que elle veut vraiment se
présenter aux français c'est moi moi
tout seul qui suis capable moi tout seul
comme les petits enfants 10 à 2 ans et
demi c'est moi qui suis capable tout
seul de vous emmener vers l'horizon que
je dessine donc ça c'est un premier
point deuxième point c'est vrai quand
même la question se pose de savoir avec
qui elle peut aller dans cette aventure
en 2017 nous avions eu le nom potentiel
enfin du potentiel le premier ministre
qu'elle nous avait donné très rapidement
c'était nicolas dupont aignan bon il y
avait eu un accord entre les deux donc
c'est effectivement ça se comprenaient
enfin là il ya effectivement personne et
lorsqu'on regarde un peu enfin ce parti
son entourage proche il n'y a pas il n'y
a qu'une personne qui a été ministre
dans le lot c'est thierry mariani avec
ce ministre de nicolas sarkozy les
autres n'ont pas d'expérience et son
maire ils sont réputés mais bon
effectivement il semble qu'ils aient
quand même un vide enfin on se demande
bien qui elle va trouver hormis quelques
figures qu'on peut distinguer çà et là
lorsqu'elle parle de façonner un
gouvernement d'union nationale
cela présuppose quand même qu'elles sont
capables d'aller aussi du côté non
seulement de l air lr ciotti mais du
côté d'une gauche souverainiste reste à
savoir comment elle va faire parce
qu'une fois qu'on a été ministre de
marine le pen je pense que là vraiment
c'est un voyage sans retour après ça
vous marque mathieu les débauchages
au profit d'eric zemmour dans l'est dans
les semaines qui ont précédé le premier
tour est-ce que ça la fragilise quand
même un peu de ce côté là certains
certains oui je pense nicolas bay je
pense à jambes rivière voilà qui étaient
chacun dans leur cour des cadres négatif
des partis d'ailleurs du comité exécutif
avec avaient des responsabilités
et
pour le reste c'est vrai que c'est le
vide abyssal autour d'eux de marine le
pen au rassemblement national d'abord
parce que faut être conscient que c'est
un parti le parti le plus démocrate de
la bande mc il ya une chef qu'est la
même chef depuis toujours et avant elle
c'était son père qui était le même chef
depuis toujours donc c'est pas un parti
on favorise la montée des cadres grande
partie des cadres de l'ère jean-marie
mélo planète c'était parti avec bruno
mégret on s'en souvient certains sont
revenus mais vous vous voyez il n'y a
pas qui on a vu monter pas grand monde
alors il ya des élus locaux c'est vrai
il y en a eu quelques-uns je pense à
david rachline on pense à louis aliot ou
steeve briois et ça constitue pas non
plus n'ont plus forcément un
gouvernement alors c'est important c'est
important dans une élection
présidentielle rappelez-vous françois
mitterrand en 1981 où la question était
posée de cette gauche qui n'ait pas été
au pouvoir depuis longtemps faisait des
affiches avec son équipe sont de son
futur gouvernement et vous aviez déjà
les contours de du gouvernement avant et
on revient ce mot que l'on me dit tu es
dans ton parler donc ça reste participer
de sa crédibilité à partie safa loire
c'est un vrai souci qu'elle a c'est avec
qui va-t-elle gouverner parce que c'est
un double chèque en blanc dans les
domaines on en a déjà parlé ici mais n'a
jamais rien géré de sa vie à part son
propre parti et de quelle façon je
l'utilisé pas de façon la plus
démocratique
en excluant j'ai ainsi compris son
propre père donc voilà c'est comme ça
qu'est la gêne c'est la seule chose
qu'elle gérait n'a jamais été maire l'a
jamais été présent dans un conseil
général et un conseil régional qu'elle
ne connaît pas ce que c'est qu'un
collectif à gérer à part celui de son
parti elle ne connaît pas non plus
l'appareil d'état puisqu'elle n'a jamais
été aux fonctionnaires uni je dis pas
que c'est un sésame mais gère ça permet
en tout cas
de connaître en tout cas les leviers
d'action et les rouages et ce double
handicap enfin ce en plus ce triple
j'allais dire parce qu'autour d'elle il
ya peu de gens il ya peu de gens et peu
de gens il ya quelques gens qui
connaissent les que les exécutifs locaux
mais très peu de gens qui connaissent
l'appareil d'état gilles finchelstein il
ya cinq ans se serait pas ou très peu
posé cette question si on se la pose on
se la posent sérieusement c'est une
première forme de victoire pour man vous
avez raison il ya vingt ans quand jean
marie le pen s'est qualifié pour le
second tour en 2002 personne à aucun
moment ne s'est posé la question et même
il ya cinq ans mais un court moment donc
où est dieu finir par lâcher le nom de
nicolas dupont aignan mais la question
n'était pas posée non plus et donc le
simple fait que la question se pose en
soi est quand même très révélateur d'une
situation c'est une situation dans
laquelle la victoire de marine le pen
devient non pas le scénario le plus
probable mais un scénario plausible
c'est un changement absolument
considérable c'est un changement
historique
ce faisant les français ils vont aussi
regarder cette fin de campagne d'un
autre oeil non et si et si c'était elle
et si c'était elle avec qui gouverne
athènes si vous souvenez d'une campagne
précédente j'y pense à l'instant en ça
devait être en 2007 quand françois
bayrou a commencé à faire une
progression spectaculaire au point à un
moment d'être en situation de se
qualifier pour le second tour le moment
où ça à calais c'est quand il a dû
essayer d'expliquer avec qui il
gouvernerait donc c'est une question qui
n'est pas une question anodine et vous
parliez des défections c'est très
intéressant parce que les défections
nombreuses dont elle a été l'objet
depuis depuis plusieurs mois ont été un
atout dans la campagne
ça a contribué à renforcer l'image que
j'évoquais tout à l'heure
c'était la victime en revanche pour
gouverner là ça devient un handicap et
elle parle d'union nationale en
commençant par exclure déjà ce qui sont
les plus susceptibles de l'arbre
notamment reconquête fait l'union
nationale ça ressemblera beaucoup au
rassemblement national alors est ce qui
a encore un front républicain on va on
va maintenant débattre autour de de
cette question écouter ce qu'en disait
l'ancien premier ministre edouard
philippe ce matin sur france inter
quant au front républicain je pense
qu'il existe encore pour beaucoup de nos
concitoyens
est-ce que c'est avec la même vigueur
qu'en 2002 manifestement non mais est-ce
qu'il n'existerait plus je ne crois pas
en tout cas je connais beaucoup de
françaises et de français de havraise de
havrais pour qui il a encore un sens est
qui et qui souhaiteront faire barrage à
une candidate qu'il
n'estime pas relever du champ
républicain le front républicain qui a
encore un sens également pour ces
sportifs de haut niveau que vous avez
peut-être vu à la une du quotidien le
parisien aujourd'hui en france une
tribune défendre les valeurs sportives
c'est combattre l'arrivée au pouvoir de
l'extrême droite le sport lieu de la
mixité refuse toutes les discriminations
c'est l'un des extraits que j'ai choisi
de cette tribune parmi les signataires
on va trouver antoine dupont demi
millier de l'équipe de france de rugby
le footballeur dimitri payet la double
championne olympique de judo clarisse
agbegnenou des légendes du sport
français tony parker marie jo pérec
laure manaudou nikola karabatic bref je
ne vais pas pouvoir les les sites est
clair chartier il ya cette tribune c'est
une manifestation de front républicain
il ya des personnalités politiques on a
on n'a pas parlé de lionel jospin hier
on aurait vu qui a appelé à voter
emmanuel macron l'ancien garde des
sceaux robert badinter le fait
aujourd'hui la difficulté est évidemment
le fera peut-être avec vous si voir ces
dad d'évaluer l'impact sur l'opinion
mais qu'est ce que ça signifie quand
même est-ce qu'il ya un petit front
républicain alors surtout je trouve que
cette mobilisation qui est à la fois
assez tardive et pour la la qui commença
à prendre corps dit bien que finalement
c'est quand même assez s'il ya un
véritable changement dit bien le
changement que nous avons connue c'est à
dire qu'auparavant nous n'aurions pas eu
besoin de voir ce genre de choses ça ça
tombait sous le sens que l'extrême
droite au pouvoir c'était inconcevable
pourquoi en sommes-nous arrivés là c'est
parce que l'expression même d'extrême
droite a été
je sais pas si galvaudé mais en tout cas
on a beaucoup glosé sur la qualification
extrême droite pour le rassemblement
national ça a contribué à complètement
troublé les esprits je pense même qu'il
ya partie des électeurs de marine le pen
s'il ne pense absolument pas voter pour
l'extrême droite je pense qu'ils pensent
voter pour une candidate populaire
presque gauchistes comme dirait eric
zemmour mais pas pour l'extrême droite
donc il ya aujourd'hui un travail de
clarification à faire parce que le front
républicain en fait il est sous tendue
par sa part cette conscience que
effectivement il y à des partis qui sont
d'extrême droite et des partis qui ne
sont pas d'extrême droite il ya des
partis qui
mettant en cause qui remettent en
question des valeurs républicaines et
d'autres non donc on voit bien qu'il ya
tout un travail qui est en train de
s'opérer parce que cette conscience là
et là je dois dire que je pense qu'il ya
dans les discussions des experts il y a
eu quand même une sorte de fourvoiement
au motif qu' on ne pouvait pas dire d'un
parti qu'il était d'extrême droite parce
qu'ils jouaient le jeu parlementaire
effectivement dans les années 30 la
caractéristique de la droite mans à
sienne action français etc c'était de ne
pas jouer le jeu parlementaire
après nous avons jean marie le pen pour
lequel nous n'avons pas eu trop de
difficultés à le qualifier d'extrême
droite et pourtant il a joué le jeu
parlementaire donc je pense que réseau
résumé la question du extrême droite
jeudi institution au jeu des
institutions c'est un peu c'est un peu
réducteur stewart show vous avez analysé
la sociologie de la jeunesse dans un
livre avec frédéric dabi publié aux
éditions les arènes la fracture c'est ça
si je me souviens du titre est ce que la
jeunesse jour je repense à la tribune
des sportifs
voilà une partie de la jeunesse
française peut être touché par leur
idole qui se mobilisent est ce que ça
peu mais même un film en mobiliser cette
jeunesse majoritairement beaucoup
d'absents abstentionnistes c'est vrai
que cette jeunesse elle est divisée en
trois blocs si on fait une lecture
générationnelle des résultats du premier
tour on a un premier bloc et un bloc
abstentionnistes on est face à une
jeunesse et on est face à une génération
d'abstention je pense que c'est plus un
effet générationnel qu'un effet d'âge
pense qu'il ya quelque chose de très
structurant qui est en train de
s'installer dans cette partie de la
jeunesse un plus de 40% de cette
jeunesse ne s'est pas rendu aux urnes
dimanche donc c'est quand même quelque
chose qui va nous interpeller au sens
politique au sens démocratique
ça c'est le premier point deuxième point
c'est effectivement une jeunesse des
18-24 primo votants qui se sont qui
s'est largement téléporter vers un vote
jean luc mélenchon il fait près 35 à 38
pour se sauver lui confère ce qui est
assez énorme il réitère un peu la
performance qu'elle effet en 2017
puisqu'il avait été aussi le candidat
des primo votants avec emmanuel macron
et puis une fracture finalement à 24 ans
25 34 qu'on a une sur représentation
effectivement de ces jeunes actifs qui
ont du mal à rentrer son âge ce travail
qui sont désabusés qui sont délaissées
qui sont abandonnés qui finalement on
leur a fait miroiter pendant un certain
temps une forme de réussite de
méritocratie qui se retrouve finalement
assez déçu de la promesse républicaine
ce sirop si on peut le dire est qu'ils
se tournent du coup vers marine le pen
pour revenir juste sur ce sur cette
question du front républicain à mon sens
la question est plus une question de
valeur que de sens c'est à dire que
calais la valeur aujourd'hui du front
républicain pour l'opinion publique
lorsque vous a vu un paratonnerre exe
moore ou le faux réplique 1 c'était
faire front pour eric zemmour et ça
n'est pas forcément pour marine le pen
je trouve que on parlait tout à l'heure
de se poser la question du gouvernement
le pen se poser la question de savoir
s'il ya un front républicain en france
révèle autant qu'il exprime une
situation dans notre pays qui est
extrêmement clivé kuhn france bifide
comme la langue du serpent ça une france
coupée en deux entre une france antilles
macro extrêmement délaissé qui se sent
abandonnée et une france aujourd'hui
qu'ils estiment peut-être effectivement
encore une fois opérant ce front
républicain donc est ce que la valeur de
cette lassitude de cette colère va être
plus importante finalement que la valeur
aujourd'hui qu'on accorde au fonds
républicains alors quelques chiffres le
baromètre ipsos sopra et steria du du
joug avec une projection sur le second
tour de cette élection présidentielle
qui donne 1 55 45 pour emmanuel macron
si on regarde la tendance alors elle est
très courte ainsi depuis dimanche soir
cette année car un petit peu plus
important puisque c'était 54 46 dimanche
soir et puis si on regarde un peu les
reports de voix ça c'est aussi
intéressant notamment chez les 7
millions 700 mille électeurs de jean luc
mélenchon je sais pas si vous avez
l'infographie la voilà ça va 37% vers
emmanuel macron 18 pour marine le pen
45% qui s'abstiennent chez jadot c'est
près de 60% vers emmanuel macron 47% des
électeurs de pécresse vont chez emmanuel
macron et 80% des fidèles d'eric zemmour
qui voteront le pen voilà je voulais
vous donner c'est ces quelques éléments
qui évidemment sont évolutifs on garde
notre prudence habituelle face à ces
projections ça évolue quasiment tous les
jours et on va ouvrir le dernier
chapitre ça se rejoint de ceux de ce
débat sur le soutien à nicolas sarkozy à
la campagne d' emmanuel macron cette
fois ci
et je vous propose pour démarrer
d'écouté l'ancien ministre du budget
eric woerth actuel président de la
commission des finances de l'assemblée
nationale ancien ministre de nicolas
sarkozy et soutient des manuels mâcon
c'était ce matin sur notre antenne si
nicolas sarkozy soutient emmanuel mâcon
qui ne le soutiennent pas nicolas
sarkozy si un homme qui aurait été un
excellent président de la république
très très puissamment fini fine et
nicolas sarkozy ça a été le patron de la
droite c'est quelqu'un qui est
profondément social qui eux voilà sa
parole elle compte
mathieu ce soutien c'était clair c'était
net soutien au président sortant qu'est
ce que ça peut changer pour un mâle
macumba c'est une vraie question il ya
du positif d'abord c'est un soutien de
poids nicolas sarkozy a certes vu son
aura à s'étioler au fil de ces défaites
électorales au fil de ses déboires
judiciaires mais c'est une personnalité
c'est un ancien président et alors où
emma daumas qu'on tente de ressusciter
ce front républicain ça peut pas faire
de mal d'autant que le prédécesseur n'a
pas ménagé ses louanges d'une certaine
façon pour son successeur dans
l'entourage emmanuel macron certains
estiment qu'à lui seul nicolas sauf que
sarkozy pourrait faire bouger un million
de voix alors c'est sans doute cher payé
nicolas sarkozy
n'est sans doute plus le grand
mamamouchi de la droite qu'il rêvait
d'être mais il conserve une réelle
influence et surtout un vrai pouvoir de
nuisance raison pour laquelle emmanuel
macron a toujours pris soin de le
traiter comme on dit on apprend
aujourd'hui dans un article très
intéressant du monde qui le lui a offert
ses chocolats préféré pour son
anniversaire à quoi ça tient parfois à
l'isolément de la tête de traces trop
non plus mais bon ça c'est pour le
positif et pour le négatif alors la
vérité c'est que en fait les règles non
écrites du ralliement c'est qu'il faut
qu'il tombe au bon moment et l'ours à ce
soutien peser préparer dès avant le
premier tour par les deux hommes ne
tombe pas forcément aujourd'hui au bon
moment je vais essayer de faire simple
emmanuel macron avait besoin de nicolas
sarkozy hier pour plombé par son
assourdissant silence la campagne de
valérie pécresse il en aura peut-être
besoin demain pour gouverner s'il
advenait que sa majorité n'était moins
confortable aujourd'hui mais aujourd'hui
on n'a plus besoin parce que le
président candidat il y en ait fait
siphonné tout ce qui pouvait à droite il
reste quasiment plus rien dans chez les
républicains on le voit avec le score de
2-2 à derry pécresse et puis surtout
nicolas sarkozy fait figure de
repoussoir absolu pour l'électorat
mélenchonistes que marine le pen
emmanuel macron se disputent pour le
second tour donc à quoi bon passé son
lundi à citer jaurès à rogner sa réponse
à mesure sur les retraites a multiplié
les gestes à l'égard de la gauche si
c'est pour brandir dès mercredi
l'épouvantail sarkozy on remarquera au
passage que la même question se pose
pour le soutien annoncé de françois
hollande qui lui aussi fait figure
d'épouvantail pour de nombreux a soumis
qu'il accuse encore d'être le fossoyeur
de la gauche du coup qu'est ce qu'on a
vu on a vu un emmanuel macron qui s'est
montrée poli reconnaissant mais distant
noyant le poisson sarkozy si j'ose dire
dans un filet beaucoup plus large de
remerciement ou l'ancien président
côtoyaient l'ancien premier ministre
lionel jospin rose hill avait fait
allusion tout à l'heure bernard
cazeneuve aussi le maire de paris on
l'ancien maire de paris pardon bertrand
delanoë est ce que nicolas sarkozy a
monnayé sa soutien alors depuis quelques
jours il confié à ses proches avoir
passé un accord avec macron un soutien
contre une cinquantaine de
circonscriptions et son mot à dire sur
le ou la futur locataire de matignon de
quoi faire bondir dans la majorité
présidentielle où les députés estiment
avoir fait le job et s'être montrés
loyaux et découvre découvrira avec
stupeur alors pour emmanuel macron ça
serait l'assurance de faire éclater l
air pour de bon et le pouvoir compter au
cas où je le disais sur quelques
soutiens supplémentaires au palais
bourbon s'il en avait besoin cerise sur
le gâteau cela lui permettrait de gâcher
un peu la vie d'edouard philippe qui lui
se rêve en grand architecte de droite de
demain avec son parti horizon mais alors
là on revient à ce petit problème de
timing le ralliement de tomber au bon
moment emmanuel macron et quand même
annoncé demain au havre pour parler
d'écologie et sa fiche est bien sûr à
côté de l'homme politique le plus
populaire de france donc edouard
philippe son ancien premier ministre pas
question de gâcher la fête c'est la
raison pour laquelle les mains de
vaincre ont expliqué ce matin qu'il
n'avait pas d'accord avec nicolas
sarkozy il faudra donc attendre encore
un peu pour payer l'addition
merci mathieu pas d'accord avec nicolas
sarkozy effectivement c'était sur france
2 ce matin qu'aucune vérité qui amène
macron a fait cette déclaration où on
pourrait rajouter pour l'instant gilles
on peut rajouter pour l'instant je peux
grand chose à ajouter à la chronique
d'une clarté cristalline de mathieu on
peut dire pour l'instant il n'y a
qu'elle va être l'effet à court terme et
je crois que ce que vient de dire
mathieu est très juste à court terme en
réalité c'est plutôt plus encombrant que
qui est dans la question à moyen terme c
est ce qu on se dirige vers une
coalition où est-ce qu'on reste sur un
parti qui à lui seul ou dans une
coalition présidentielle qui à elle
seule à la majorité la coalition à
l'allemande on commença
à beaucoup faire cette référence je ne
sais pas du tout dans notre tradition et
de notre histoire politique mais non
c'est fin c'est pas notre culture
politique malgré tout vous avez eus sous
la vème république de très très très
nombreux de gouverne du gouvernement qui
étaient des gouvernements de fait des
gouvernantes coalition s'était recueilli
plusieurs parties qui composaient le
gouvernement a la singularité de la
situation actuelle était qu'il y en a
qui n'y en avait qu'un est ce que l'on
on peut quand même commencé à connaître
du comporte d'une tempérament d'emmanuel
macro c'est que si il peut ne pas avoir
de coalition et donc s'il peut garder
davantage de pouvoirs pour lui il n'en
serait sans doute pas mécontent est-ce
qu'on peut évaluer stewart le poids d'un
ralliement enfin alors je ralliement ou
d'un soutien on va dire ça comme ça de
nicolas sarkozy puisque l'accord quand
j'entends on va te dire que les l'époque
certains projets macro disent ça pèse 1
million de voix alors c'est compliqué de
l'évaluer dans l'opinion puisque tout le
monde dira dans l'opinion que ça n'a
aucun aucun impact et plus on ira
effectivement et sûre sur les études ça
le monde montre très bien à faire que
les ralliements les appels au vote
souvent même sont des figures tutélaires
ont très peu d'impact sérieux sur des
gens qui sont convaincus ils seraient
allés voter même s'il n'y avait pas eu
d'appel et plus des gens qui hésitent et
continueront quand même à hésiter la
question que je me pose toutefois c'est
l'image que ça renvoie de la posture des
manuels macron sur cet entre deux tours
ça cette espèce de fébrilité ou a jamais
eu besoin effectivement être à la
recherche de partenaires de grands
partenaires finalement il sait il s'est
convaincu lui-même que tout pouvait
suffire à sa marque et là on sent quand
même une sorte de fragilité a essayé de
chercher des z à droite à gauche pour
essayer de former ce futur gouvernement
ou cette future majorité présidentielle
je trouve à mon sens que ça délivre une
image plutôt de fragilité sur ce début
de 2ème temps de campagne qui me semble
quand même assez particulier d'autant
plus que à mon sens c'est ce que disait
mathieu est très juste le siphonnage de
la droite c'est à dire la jambe droite
emmanuel macron elle est plutôt en bon
état je pense qu'il faut maintenant pour
l'huissier de 2,2 de parfaire sa jambe
gauche et pour le coup je pense qu'un
message nicolas sarkozy pour l'électorat
de gauche de conquête emmanuel macron
c'est pas forcément un message très
positif j'entends à nathalie schuck ce
matin sur rtl qui disait départ ça
devait être un 20h et que effectivement
au vu des résultats du premier tour ça
un peu rétro pédaler pour que le message
de nicolas sarkozy deviennent simplement
voilà ce communiqué sur facebook si on
se projette alors là on a fait
l'hypothèse marine le pen qui
l'emportent en début de débat si on est
dans l'hypothèse où emmanuel macron
l'emportent qu'est ce qui se passe au
matin du 25 avril c'est là qu'à huit
formations différentes au sein de sa
majorité
aujourd'hui perspective législatives en
tout cas je voudrais juste revenir un
instant sur les allées droit de ne pas
répondre à la mission non mais parce que
je trouve que c'est la nouveauté la
petite nouveauté juste mais insisté sur
ce point là emmanuel macron certes on
peut le sentir fébrile il a introduit la
danse show très récemment cette idée de
nouveautés je vais bouger je veux faire
quelque chose de neuf et c'est quoi la
nouveauté c'est la coalition donc
agressé les retraites un papa oui mais
je voudrais d'un point de vue plus large
politique des retraites effectivement
c'est une mesure mais tf1 pas technique
elle engage de tout un projet de société
mais mais quand même ça c'est quelque
chose de très très neuf dont il ya
quelque chose qui est en train de bouger
là qui est complètement faux a tout à
fait étranger comme on l'a dit à notre
culture même si on a eu les cohabitation
avec un président premier ministre donc
c'est quand même quelque chose là on a
déjà deux de quoi en très très opposées
qui doivent composer
donc là on a une nouveauté qui
s'installe et nicolas sarkozy dans cette
nouvelle optique il a quand même son
utilité c'est pour ça que je voulais
revenir là dessus parce que je ne suis
pas certaine que ce soit ce poids à ce
point un poids quant au million de voix
peut-être serait fertile aux millions de
lecteurs qu'il a avec ses best-sellers
et en faisant le calcul de façon assez
primaire la culture de coalition on l'a
pas parce qu'on n'a pas le régime qui
favorise la gym parlementaire où on le
sait la coalition se fait suite aux
élections et où dans ces pays là on
passe parfois deux mois trois mois six
mois à faire un programme de coalition
s'est pas du tout dans la culture
française du fait majoritaire où le
gagnant remporte et là la minorité n'a
rien c'est ça serait un bouleversement
total mais qui se devrait se doubler mon
avis oui du nahd d'une réforme
institutionnelle et ses profondes merci
beaucoup merci à tous d'avoir participé
à ce débat stewart show je rappelle le
titre de votre livre l'opinion des
émotions qui est publié aux éditions de
l'aube et puis gilles finchelstein ce
dossier le pen idéologie images
électorat publié par la fondation jean
jaurès